all month long we are highlighting
hispanic heritage month dr edith
fernandez is the vice president of
college and community engagement at
nevada state college and she's made a
career in higher education for a good 25
years 25 years wow dr fernandez
graduated with a bachelor's degree from
unr got her masters at harvard and phd
from the university of michigan but as
sally jaramillo tells us her true roots
are right here in southern nevada
yeah you know education for me
i mean in essence it's this it's a it's
a human
right and i keep coming back because
there's a need dr edith fernandez is a
first generation american she graduated
from bonanza high school and achieving
her dream of getting her phd she says
her parents were the ultimate role
models it really stuck with me how they
worked so very hard dr fernandez says
they always gave back to the community
despite the circumstances well as a vice
president my role
i'm not involved in the academics of the
day-to-day per se but part of a team
that helps kind of create an environment
that is
attracts students at nevada state
college fernandez along with her
colleagues work together to shape what a
college should look like and serve the
students of today one of the things i'm
very proud of
that i helped fund was
this program called
napatla is a summer bridge program
and napala is an aztec word specifically
a not wall word
that means in the middle focusing on
first generation latino students who
won't just be getting a degree these are
students who are leaving their homes for
the very first time and entering the
college space while also learning how to
be independent and build relationships i
think we have the potential to
really be kind of a hub for
new
latino thought leaders fernandez has
made a notable difference in helping
students who come from undeserved
communities pursue a college education
another program she is proud of
thedream.us
right now we have over 120
undocumented students that have a full
ride scholarship four years i'm really
proud of that program because it's not
just a
a program where the foundation commits
to giving
money
literal dollars but then the institution
nevada state commits to
advising and mentoring her message to
all the students in the valley well i
had to start with the chaleganas i mean
i
look within their own family or even
outside like for those kind of role
models of what you aspire to be sally
garamillo 8 news now